all right guys
bang bang got ryan here super excited to
do this uh thanks so much for doing it
man
yeah thanks for having me on look
forward to it we are recording this on a
very big day for you guys at kingdom
trust but before we talk about all of
the uh the fun and exciting stuff
let's uh just cover your background for
people that don't know you kind of
where'd you grow up what did you do
before you ever discovered bitcoin or
crypto
yeah yeah i so i grew up i'm a southern
boy grew up in the
grew up in the south uh my dad that was
a football player he played for the
falcons and then retired down in hilton
head
um so i was a was a football player
played against your old
old school cardinal gibbons uh from
north carolina and um
uh but went to uh studied at duke and
then when i was at duke really
got shaped by you know by the
you know like the academic world and
remember getting a phone call
from my parents about halfway through
when i was at duke and
i was pre-law at the time and i got a
call from them back in 2000
into 2007 early 2008 that they lost
everything
and i remember i was you know sitting
there in school i only cared about
football and
girls and whatever you whatever you care
about when you're when you're that age
and i was like what do you mean they
lost you lost everything like what are
you talking about i grew up
you know fairly comfortable ex-nfl
player et cetera
and they're like yeah everything's gone
it's like evaporated and i was like well
surely this is not possible so i ended
up like looking into it actually pivoted
my whole life
from going pre-law to studying economics
and specifically like macroeconomics and
you know from there became like really
disenfranchised with this whole
i figured out actually how money worked
when i was there so
i got really disenfranchised with the
way the legacy financial system worked
uh actually what economics meant and at
that point
when i graduated was 2009 and there was
nobody hiring back then unless you were
either a bank
you're going into law school or med
school
that was it so went and worked in the
financial
markets before bitcoin and i remember
how much i
just hated it and you know i'm kind of
in the middle of this like a lot of us
were at that time like this period of
really
deep frustration with what's going on
the legacy system and then bam in 2011
beginning of 2012 someone sent me this
white paper and you know so the story
goes
so i grew up as a football southern
football player you know american
i love america um and you know i
uh and now you know full-time bitcoiner
yeah it's so interesting to hear kind of
your take on uh the 2008 2009 crisis
uh you are one year ahead of me in
school
and i always say that there's probably
like a five-year
kind of band uh or demographic of kids
who were in college or kind of right
after or right before
uh when that happened we didn't have
enough financial assets personally to
really be affected
right we saw parents friends parents
like
we saw the kind of economic carnage and
it gave us a front row seat without
actually kind of getting hurt personally
and i think it really drove a lot of
people to say like
what the hell is this what is going on
right and drive people to
uh just learn more about it which you
know in today's day and age obviously
that education proves to be super
helpful but also to let a lot of people
do bitcoin as well
yeah i mean there's no doubt and i look
at like i'm drawing on similarities
right now with what we're going through
and i remember the date it was the end
of 2007 when the banks foreclosed on
them
and they lived in that house for it was
basically a year after
where we really felt anything massive
that was going on
and i it's i'm looking at the same thing
right now and i see the same
you know videos that you're that you see
on twitter where you see like endless we
works
and like endless commercial buildings
that are just empty and it's got
i have that same eerie feeling but like
this time around
i feel fortunate to have gone through
that at a period where
obviously it was terrible for my family
but i i'm definitely
have come at the you know this crisis
that we're in right now with an entirely
different
mindset and understanding of okay it's
not
you know i understand what's happening
right now and you know now this time
around we all have different choices
like we have exit signs that we can look
at uh and it's totally you know i'm
super grateful to have gone through that
period it was a very impressionable
period for me but and now i feel like we
have something
that we can add to this crisis here that
helps people realize that there is an
exit and that's part of my mission here
is to
you know make sure that we are educating
the
people that were hurt the last time
around that this this crisis we actually
have
uh an exit sign for you and that's
basically what i've dedicated my entire
life to doing
yeah i love that tell us a little bit
more once you saw the bitcoin white
paper read through it uh kind of how did
you transition
out of the legacy financial system into
working on uh bitcoin-related things
well i mean immediately the first thing
i thought about when i read the white
paper was like holy crap this is like
awesome like finally austrian economics
has something
to hang our hat on like that was the
first thing that hit me and everyone's
like what are you
like what are you talking about this is
some like bubble technology
internet monopoly money and i looked at
it and i saw this
like scarce programmatic monetary supply
i was like well holy cow there's
something really serious here that
is like deeper when you start you know
coming in that age where i just learned
like what we did with
uh you know money supply and like
anthony inflate it since the 70s i
realized that there's something deeper
here
and what i went on this like realization
that for the last
30 years really since like we ended the
gold standard 40 years
um austrian economics has this like gold
argument like it's some put on society
and
it's a very negative argument and it
isn't necessarily
trying like it we haven't had a tool to
out compete
uh the other side of the argument really
it's been like the other side is gonna
fail
and we have this gold standard and when
i read the bitcoin white paper i
realized that
wait a second in a digital age we have
something here that can actually compete
uh rather than us just banking on the
legacy system failing
so as soon as i realized that back then
i was like i gotta dedicate you know
after going
through what i went through with my
family and seeing like everything ripped
from them without
even having a clue what was going on i
just realized that i need to dedicate
every hour of my life towards you know
expanding and advancing this
this reality so that's right then and
there is when
you know as is what i saw i didn't you
know people that i've worked with
obviously like melt them at coin shares
they come at things from like uh
they're they're a lot more tech focused
in this space when i came at it from
like this
weird place where my family lost
everything i'm disenfranchised with this
kind of
keynesian experience experiment that i
grew to understand while at duke
and now i saw this like okay now we have
a gladiator in the arena
with austrian economics it's not some
like bet that the other side is going to
fail
it's like a competitor so that was my
big like eureka moment it wasn't the
tech it wasn't anything like that it was
the
it was this like gladiator that we have
in the arena now
yeah it's a really interesting way to
look at uh most people
point a finger and say oh they're gonna
fail and the only other option would be
gold you know standard or something like
that what you're basically saying is no
no
we don't need to wait for that other
system to fail
actually now here's a thing that can one
go compete but also two
if it is the better system the market
will determine that and it will eclipse
it
over time right it's almost like this
more offensive position
than just a defensive kind of
wait-and-see approach
that's exactly it and you know i think
that even
even now like you hear a lot of our
fellow bitcoiners that will kind of
point at some
you know a sovereign currency blowing up
and say you know this is why you should
own
yes that is a part of the narrative but
like we are out competing right now you
look at
you know squirt what savers are doing
with like square each quarter what like
you're seeing the charles schwab
millennials buying gbtc you're seeing
you know the movement of us with the
fidelity announcement we're moving the
ball forward it's not it's it's out
competing it's not just
a narrative that the other system is is
collapsing we're seeing a
exactly what i i hoped would have seen
uh back in 2011
12 when you read that white paper the
first time so i'm just you know i'm
waiting for
i think we still have obviously it's
still early and things like that but
it is not just this kind of sit back and
wait for the old system to fail we're
going to advance this
and be competitive and and earn the
belief and the and the users not just
inherit them when a debt-based system
fails and that's
that's a critical thing that i think
most people that are on the other side
of the fence don't understand is that
we don't view this as a we're here for
when you guys screw up we view it as
we're going to kick your butt
and you know i think you know that's a
big part of the bitcoin community right
now
and it's it's fostered from what satoshi
was really looking to
to build i love it um tell me more about
coin shares you ever started a business
that ended up growing into a very very
large business kind of what was the
impetus for the idea and how did you
guys get started
yeah back then it was really cool to say
that we're you know you're going to
build this like regulated framework for
bitcoin and to advance it and that was
like the cool thing that everyone was
saying and you know we saw
really what happened is i was working
for a fintech so post banking post wells
fargo when i came out of duke i was
working for a fintech
miss fintech helped companies hedge
their currency risk
uh which was really cool like twitter
google uber all these companies use it
to click a button and see okay here's my
vietnamese dong to dollar exposure
and they moved me to london uh to expand
that fintech business into asia pack
uh and and um emea uh so
i was sitting there in the forefront of
like right in the crossroad of like tech
and currencies and
i looked at what the winklevosses and
the solid x guys were doing at the time
you know my fellow american counterparts
were making no progress
with the exchange traded product
discussion and again what that era of
people were trying to do was put like
regulated
wrappers around bitcoin we still are in
many cases to advance it and i looked at
okay well london is like the third
largest etf market behind japan and new
york uh or or the united states
and i was like wait a second nobody's
really taking control of that narrative
over here in europe and we have this
uh amazing platform here so that was the
birth that was it that was the that was
the goal of coin shares was to advance
uh the regulatory footprint and the
regulated digital asset platform for
europe and and
globally and we did that and along the
way we launched
exchange trade products on the nasdaq um
you know bitcoin ethereum
litecoin we then um you know we expanded
that outs
brought on melton which was a massive
part of the growth both in the us
as well as over what we were doing with
managed strategies and giving investors
the ability to express into some of the
more cutting edge parts of the space
that you couldn't put in the etp wrapper
and now coin chairs is still kicking
butt i mean they're you know we've got
they've just hired uh two people that
came in from wisdomtree
uh to expand that institutional
footprint into the rest of europe and
and asia and you know jean-marie melton
danny
frank and that team is you know they're
they're kicking butt so i'm super pumped
that
you know that the company is doing as
well as it is and it's very mission
focused too is to advance our industry
and
and keep pushing the regulatory
structure to help people
gain access and exposure to our space i
just need to get back to the us
what was the kind of biggest lessons
learned right as you went out to build
this business
uh over the last couple of years
obviously grew to to quite a large size
uh you spoke with everyone from
regulators to traditional financial
firms to
institutional investors like what are
some of the takeaways either that
surprised you
or people watching and listening
wouldn't necessarily know what you think
is
kind of really good uh data points for
them to understand
yeah i think you know from my standpoint
i
you know i beat my i think what most
people don't understand is how actually
how few institutions
uh were you know we're in the market up
until i think this year
really you know we we i beat every door
down in europe i mean i talked to every
pension fund
and maybe i was just too american and
too uh you know
too much of a sales focus guy but you
know we didn't see
any institutional movement whatsoever
and then all of a sudden
we figured out over in europe that these
products could be open
access to the grassroots movement where
they could trade these in their
retirement accounts
and it just exploded and you know we saw
our investors go from like a few
thousand to
30 000 plus once we figured out that
a way of kind of positioning into the
pension accounts over in europe
and i think that so what's interesting
i'm curious to see
what the stats end up being through the
rest of 2020 and you know we saw this
big
paul tudor jones announcement but from
my experience like i have not
been able to move the needle as much in
the institutional market as i have the
grassroots
retail movement because i still despite
with all of the
announcements that are going on about
xyz institution doing this
you know i still think that we are way
in the grassroots retail movement
and i haven't seen many companies move
the needle yet
uh so i would say that to most
bitcoiners kind of
frustration is probably what i what i
saw the most there
and if i would have spent more time i
would spend more time on retail and less
time on institutions back then
yeah it's really really interesting
because uh robert kiyosaki has this
framework where he basically talks about
gold and silver as like god's money
and bitcoin as the people's money right
this idea of
you know it is so democratized it is so
transparent
uh and it has been adopted by the people
first it's one of the first assets if
not the first asset where
kind of the institutions the wall street
firms the you know quote-unquote wealthy
and elite
didn't beat retail to it right it is the
everyday person who actually has
benefited from bitcoin more so than
many of those institutions yeah and i
you know i
like you can have them like i know that
like i'm pumped that
for my fellow bitcoiners that are out
there in the institutional grind every
day like i'm pumped that they're doing
it
but you know we don't i like i look at
the community and
part of me says well we don't need them
um and i think that is still what's
really cool about like our
our grassroots movement maybe that's
just like my socialization coming out of
the 2009 when i saw these institutions
just kind of
throw up on main street uh and i view i
view this as still like a
a people's movement um against that but
you know we'll see i mean i think
i do think however the paul tudor jones
um
piece was the single most uh changing
uh or dynamic for the institutional
market i've seen in the last
six years since i've really been
focusing here uh and i think that you
know he really de-risked
the career risk um of you know
institutions
expressing a view here so we'll see you
know that is exciting and
i think that there's you know now
obviously we have some big names like
fidelity and
the others that's you know nomura and
kamenu with coin shares
we have some big names that are starting
to lean into this and
i'm excited to see what the next two or
three years holds around that but for me
uh i'm gonna stay focused on you know
the on the grassroots part of it
and we're gonna kate you know we're
gonna cater to bitcoiners
and i'm really excited to see the amount
of like bitcoin native
financial service companies that are
kind of focused on that i think that's
just as important
as what the work is that our brothers
and sisters are doing on the
institutional side
so so you came back to the united states
uh and
you now are the ceo of kingdom trust and
so maybe talk us through a little bit
kind of what happened how do you guys
um you know acquire that asset and then
kind of what's the plan in terms of what
you guys trying to go build
yeah so you know it was time just to
come back
uh i i was in london for uh supposed to
be
eight months turned into five and a half
years uh and
i love it there i think um you know it
was kind of at the point of my life
where i wanted to be back in the united
states
grew up here i've got uh my dad
obviously playing football has
become very sick uh it's public out
there and i needed to you know be here
on the ground kind of in the south but
really the main driver commercially was
you know i talked about what we saw in
the retirement market in europe
and i look back here and you know i saw
this charles schwab report where the top
five holdings
of millennials and schwab was gbtc and
you know i saw this like massive
28 trillion dollar market that
was just screaming oh my god like it's
just
yelling at me so i realized that okay
this is an opportunity i think it's
the single largest addressable market
for bitcoin right now so
uh i naturally as someone that's looking
to advance bitcoin solve this as a
reason that i need to go
i need to go advance it i need to go
jump into that and advance that so if
you study the us retirement market
kingdom trust was the first qualified
custodian
ever to custody bitcoin so as a
bitcoiner i love that
um you know it's a company in murray
kentucky so it's like middle america
like there's no airport in murray
kentucky you know you gotta drive two
and a half hours
to the closest airport and it's just
this like middle america company that i
saw as a roots to kind of build this
20-year business of advancing bitcoin
and retirement accounts so i just fell
in love with it and i think the people
we have 80 people there and i just
thought it was a perfect platform to
keep advancing bitcoin
and specifically in the retirement
market uh so that was really the the
crux of it and
what we saw there got it and so
obviously you guys have been uh
advertising uh on the podcast and other
places uh
choice which is a self-directed ira
product so maybe just explain kind of
philosophically like what is the point
of
using tax advantage dollars to buy
bitcoin
and then we could talk about
mechanically how it actually works
yeah so like a group i think taking a
step back about that
we as bitcoiners it's amazing you look
at our industry we're doing all these
things like
stacking sats every day and like
counting the exact amount of coin that
we are
accumulating and you it's like a for
some it's a hobby for others it's a
lifestyle
and what's interesting is that none of
us most of us and i look at
look at kind of the rest of my fellow
bitcoiners like most of us aren't
thinking anything about
the the tax element of this and if we're
gonna hodl
or hold for a long period of time or
maybe never sell
uh or if you're gonna trade for trade in
and out
you know what are the most tax advantage
ways where you keep more coin to
yourself
and you know what i that was a big part
of why i felt it was so important to
like advance bitcoin in the retirement
market so the idea here
and what we've launched is the product
called choice and choice
is a way for you to invest in the
digital assets
market or the legacy market from one
retirement account so today
in your schwab account you can only
trade like zombie legacy
federal like stocks and stuff in the
legacy
system bitcoin is not okay they don't
let you do that
um and then before it was only you you
could only trade crypto but none of the
legacy stuff
so we viewed that as a problem and we
wanted to integrate the two worlds so
choice is a way for you to have choice
as an investor
between the legacy markets in the
digital market you can trade any stock
or etf
plus any cryptocurrency from one account
and i think that's
and that's important because now you can
start huddling and trading
in a tax deferred way instead of just in
your uh
you know in your non-tax qualified
accounts so as a hodler you're becoming
more more elevated and sophisticated and
thinking not just
how much coin i'm accumulating but how
much
net coin am i accumulating after taxes
and i think coindesk did a great piece
on it today
uh on tax on just the concept of tax and
bitcoin
and i think we need more thought leaders
that are just hammering that uh not it's
not just about retirement there's other
things that matter as well
yeah and so obviously one of the things
that uh people hear about
um is hey i'd love to use my tax
advantage dollars in my retirement
account to buy bitcoin but historically
i haven't been able to hold the private
keys right there's been ways to do it
but
it's kind of been indirect exposure so i
buy some asset and that asset that gives
me the exposure but i actually want to
hold bitcoin and i think to me this was
the the most fascinating part is
you guys figured out how somebody could
use those tax advantage dollars buy
bitcoin and still retain their private
keys
so let me talk a little bit just how
mechanically you guys are actually doing
that
yeah so the so you're right i mean most
it most of the
pretty much gbtc dominated the u.s
retirement market
up until now and recently with with what
we've launched with choice and
the idea is that i believe every bitcoin
company ceo
has a responsibility uh for its bitcoin
users to help them own their own keys
right so in a retirement account the
most the best way of doing that
is what you do is you set up a
retirement account with choice
and then under the retirement account
you actually form
a what's called a single member trust or
single member llc
and that's in that single member llc and
trust actually holds the coins
and you can hold those uh yourself and
this originated back in the gold days
there was a bunch of gold bugs that
wanted to have you know not have the
gold at deutsche bank
and wanted to hold it in their
retirement account themselves so what
was structured between the legal the
regulatory
uh the back and forth between lawyers
and the irs is that
a retirement account could be structured
in a way where you can have it at the
top level
with a single member llc and trust
underneath it uh and then you can hold
the keys yourself
uh underneath that and your requirement
is to report back
uh the positions of that uh to the
custodian once uh
for the irs annual filings um so it's
amazing that this structure exists it's
been
in place for a long time we have people
that own much more than just bitcoin you
can own fire trucks
you can own physical gold you'd be it's
amazing
what types of assets are held so it's
also really uh
holding your own keys if you're getting
into bitcoin is
sometimes not it can be daunting so
there's a again as a as a my goal
is to advance bitcoin in the u.s
retirement market and i think along the
way
we've identified partners that can help
us do that the most and i think
so what we've done is we've powered this
solution using casa so casa has
developed a
really good user interface app and then
the hardware
compatibility with owning your own keys
in a multi-sig capacity
and they just nailed the user experience
so that was a
we were able to take that what they've
built which is another
uh bitcoin company and we could just use
that to streamline this as a service
so before you had to set up all this
crazy stuff to own your own keys now
it's like an out-of-the-box
product so as a as a bitcoin ceo i feel
that we've got
a good solution now for our users
that have the ideological requirement as
i do to hold your own keys
but then also to have other choices
hence the our brand
to either hold them in cold storage with
us or put those coins in motion
uh in the evolving and upcoming bitcoin
money market and capital markets layer
which i'm pretty excited about
um so it's those three things starting
with the nucleus being hold your own
keys and then extending out from there
explain that last bit a little bit in
terms of uh kind of that money market or
the financial layer what do you mean by
that
so what's what's fascinating about
if you look at the trajectory of legacy
financial system
we went from owning you know having
your gold or whatever else there at your
house
and it was in your possession it was
safe then
we started depositing that into
financial organizations
somewhere along the way we messed up and
and detached gold from the dollars
we ended up keeping dollars with the
banks and then to keep them at the banks
the tr what they did is they started
saying hey guess what we're going to
earn interest on your savings
we're going to deliver interest to you
so in lieu of you not having your cash
or gold
beneath your mattress we are going to
deliver interest for having at our
financial organization
and believe it or not i actually think
that we're going to take the same path
as an industry i think way this is going
to work in the next five
10 years is that you're either going to
own your own keys
or you're going to be paid on the risk
for not having them yourselves
and in order for that market to evolve
we are seeing you have a quite a bit of
maturity that needs to take place
um over the last three or four years of
these regulated prime brokers
uh and the likes so that i can put that
bitcoin in motion with other regulated
financial institutions and earn interest
on it
so what you're seeing over the last
three years
is this really healthy capital market
slayer
and what i call bitcoin money market
layer that emer has
emerging between all these massive prime
brokers that you've got that are
regulated with deep balance sheets i
mean you've seen
coin chairs the backed galaxy uh the
bitgo
the genesis the fidel you know you have
all of these amazing outlets jane street
sasquahana citadel and what's happening
is you're seeing this really
good layer of digital asset capital
formation that's emerging
that's allowing people to tap into it so
what's
what what i think is really cool is that
yes i can own my own keys and have
the largest percent of my assets you
know in my possession
but i also want to put some of that to
work and earn
interest and yield on that so basically
the way that we are going to be
structuring our products is to helping
users do that
um and that's that whole industry is
blossoming because it isn't just about
the money markets you're also seeing
like the origination of d5 and there's
other stuff emerged from that
but before d5 and all that stuff there's
some basic lending that's going on
where the interest rates are really
competitive
and why they're competitive is not
because it's some dangerous
uncollateralized market it's because
that their natural commercial interest
rates
that aren't being manipulated at the
short end of the curve by
by central banks so you're seeing these
healthy bitcoin
money market and interest rate markets
that are emerged
and savers love that and we're seeing
you know
we are seeing massive demand with our
hundred thousand users at kingdom
for those types of products so people
want to hold their own keys with casa
but they also want to take a piece of
that and put it in motion and i think
what's cool about our industry is the
the better counterparties that we get
into this like fidelity
you know and all these others that uh
money market capital market slayer is
really starting to mature nicely
and giving you a lot of really good
options versus the legacy financial
system
good luck getting uh any interest on
your cash probably any more ever for
for as far as we can see so that's what
i see emerging and what i think
is really interesting right now yeah
it's also
um a very different framework to kind of
pit
investors versus savers right and i
think that in the legacy world
savers have basically held on to an
asset that's been devalued over time so
inflation eats away at the savings
uh it ends up not performing that well
uh even if you get into you know kind of
the best performing money market funds
you're still talking about
you know kind of inflation uh mitigation
maybe you get a couple of basis points
of outperformance over inflation but but
it's frankly flat right right um whereas
investors you know if you've just been
in the stock market you're doing 89
annualized year over year now all of a
sudden here comes this piece of sound
money
in bitcoin and the savers of bitcoin
have been compounding the growth rate at
like 35 plus percent
year over year for year after year after
year after year
and you now are getting in this weird
world where like the investment
class is being outperformed by a savers
class
the savior's class just is holding a
different type of assets maybe talk a
little bit about that
yeah i mean you're no doubt that's
what's happening i think you've got this
weird dichotomy of
of in our industry and perception of our
industry for that matter that bitcoin
is the only the only kind of people that
are bitcoins are some speculative
punters
no no if you talk to the most of us in
syria's community it's not an investment
they literally are talking about it in
terms of their savings it's their life
savings
so now you know what we're seeing to
your point that you just made
is there's what's the only thing that's
outperforming your savings are these
other vehicles that generate cash
cash flow on those savings because it's
rooted with hard money
and quality money so now what you're
seeing is that market's getting so big
as you said it ranges from eight to 30
percent annualized per year on your
interest
well now when you have margin that
that's that big
guess what happens the counter parties
that come in and service that market
start to improve materially so what you
see
is that you start to see balance
investment grade balance sheets come in
and starts to provide services around
that type of interest rate market
jane street citadel susquehanna coin you
know these big names
so it's super bullish for us and i know
that you know there's a
percentage of the followers here in
bitcoin that may say that that's like
blasphemy
for um you know us to ever think about
putting coin outside of our own
casa account or our own cold storage but
it's it's not the way that it works it's
ca
it's actually capitalism um you want to
have your savings and
hold that not at a bank but have it
yourself but then you want to put a
little bit of your savings to motion put
it to work
and i think that you're seeing that
extension attract some really high
quality counterparties now
that are investment grade balance sheets
to come in and capture that and i think
it's only going to grow i think you're
going to see
that become one of the biggest stories
in bitcoin over the next three to five
years is
the capital markets layer emergence
around that in the interest market layer
the challenge that we face as an
industry quite honestly is that
when you have the money supply that is
decentralized
right so not government-backed um we
have to figure out how we are going to
handle our version of an fdic
right so the fdic is put in place for
the u.s dollar money markets
uh that's there as a bank fail-safe um
well
you know the bitcoiner in me would say
well you know
what's about to happen in nine months
when 60 of the u.s
community banks are about to you know be
out of that cash
but where's fdic going to be then but
the taking a step back still looking at
that problem objectively
we still have that that um problem
or that matter that we need to address
as a community is that
if you're going to frame it in a money
market or in a interest-bearing
world where are the where are those risk
perimeters and i think it's a really
interesting discussion there's going to
be a lot of
uh good debate got a lot of good debate
and formation on that in the coming
years
but what we do know is that the market
is speaking and is speaking loud
and you know those interest rates are
attracting big names
and i don't think that's going to stop
anytime soon yeah you know obviously
we're big investors in the company
called block fights like up to six
percent i think they offer on bitcoin
and then the other thing too that uh is
really interesting to me is some of
these other types of products right so
uh they've got a product that basically
you can deposit bitcoin
and get a us dollar loan against it so
you don't have to sell your
bitcoin but you can get some us dollar
liquidity uh and
as we kind of unpacked it what shocked
me was using bitcoin as the collateral
ends up making it lower risk than most
collateralized loans right
because what they'll do is they'll
actually take an over collateralization
so to give you kind of 30 to 50 ltv
and then if at any point there is price
volatility
they're sitting on an asset that is
highly divisible right so they can only
sell fractions of the asset
into a very liquid market and that's a
way for them to actually drastically
reduce the risk right
you know i always tell the equivalent of
uh a car loan
usually you take out the loan but you
take the car you drive around
and the bank can't come and say okay you
gotta sell the front you know the front
door
right okay we're gonna sell the back
seat this time yeah
it doesn't work that way no it doesn't
it doesn't and it's you know it's
fascinating
and i agree you got it and that's like
part of the benefits again this is
awesome this goes back to my point
this is we have hard sound money at the
nucleus here
right and when you put that at the
nucleus you can start to see really
healthy capital formation like
capital market slayers start to emerge
around that because as long as you have
this hard money at you know out
competing the
this is the issue with debt based money
and you know this is another example of
us
out competing and i think you're going
to see this capital markets layer
get more interesting you're you have
more and more people that are switching
their belief of bitcoin from this
speculative thing
into oh this is my this is my
inflation-adjusted savings that like
that
that i'm now going to leverage uh rather
than
this is me taking a punt right and i
think the the amount of people in that
community is growing
at as we speak right now uh and with
that
as block five's been one of the most
cutting-edge companies in that arena
you're starting to see these really good
options as a saver and
uh the counterparty risk is improving
and proving they're still i mean look
the other day though just like the gold
guys have been telling us for
300 years it's like 3 000 years whatever
it's not your coins uh you know not your
keys not your coins
but now i have optionality and choices
uh as a saver
on different different things to do
there and it's really i'm excited for it
yeah and i think a key piece you know
you said it a couple times and i think a
lot of people who are excited about
those types of companies
basically say look don't put 100 of your
savings into
kind of uh revenue generating or cash
flow generating type
activities or put it to work right save
90 or whatever the number is that you're
comfortable with and take a small
portion and go ahead and use that as
risk capital
um it's a very kind of uh you know
not risky approach to getting some yield
but also
making sure that uh that for the
majority of it you're holding
kind of your keys and you've got that
sovereignty um today you guys obviously
announced a
a really big deal with uh fidelity so
maybe talk a little bit about what uh
what exactly was announced
yeah so what we today we announced that
we have
um and choice you have three options as
we just talked about you can either hold
your keys
uh for your bitcoin you can put your
bitcoin in air gap cold storage with
someone else or you can lev
you can put your bitcoin in motion into
these markets later that we talked about
um we you know as a mission what i'm
trying to do
is trying to deliver the best possible
choice choices to our
customers and as a subset of that as you
just heard i'm trying to advance bitcoin
in the u.s retirement market so what we
announced
uh and what we're proud to be a part of
and humbled is to leverage the fidelity
institutional platform and team and use
that platform
to give access to it to the united
states retail and retirement market
through choice our product so fidelity
is powering the bitcoin
cold storage if you choose that option
to instead of owning your own keys to
keep it with fidelity
and i think it's important because you
know we as we talked about we're
i think there's a lot of people with
retirement accounts or that are looking
at bitcoin and are kind of waiting
all right well fidelity's involved i've
got my 401k my ira with fidelity
if they're holding it you know i've been
hearing about it from
from you pomp or from everyone else for
three to five years maybe
you know maybe it's time and i think us
being able to have the opportunity to
leverage
their institutional products and provide
access to that for retail is what uh is
what we've done there and we're
we're very uh we're very excited about
it i think it's big for bitcoin
i think it's big for the u.s retirement
market
and i hope it's just the first step of
many more to come
as the fidelity digital assets
team and mission continues to grow
and i think they have been a massive
contributor to our movement and makes
thrilled to be able to work with their
team
tom and christine and and uh and the
whole group over there
uh are really cool to work with yeah and
one of the things that you guys are
doing so obviously
working with folks like fidelity
obviously is a very big kind of stamp of
uh validation if you will to some degree
and uh people kind of trust that brand
but also uh we had to pass their
diligence uh that's for sure
yeah but there's also this element of
like if i want to
take my retirement account turn it into
a self-directed ira right which i've
done
um i've got a choice account personally
is
i also not boxed into just bitcoin right
which i actually think is a really
important piece of this because you and
i are
you know kind of hardcore believers of
hardcore believers and
and frankly we probably are willing to
take much more risk when it comes to an
asset like bitcoin
than most people but if i wanted to
i could actually go buy stocks i could
go buy other alternative assets i could
kind of do all of this stuff out of this
self-directed ira
and so i don't get pigeonholed and
saying oh if i convert my
retirement account into this new
structure then like basically i have to
keep it in bitcoin forever
so maybe talk a little bit about like
the optionality that people have
and why you look at that as a positive
yeah it's it's amazing like we looked at
um you know you look at the retirement
market and
you know what's happened last three or
four years is that there's been some of
these
companies that have emerged and they
just do bitcoin only and they charge and
what you have to do is you have to sell
all of your stocks and all of your
mutual funds and you have to move cash
over to this group
and they're charging like 10 on the way
in so 10 of every
everything you move in they're charging
uh and you know it's amazing where you
having to dump over you'll manage this
stuff over here at your schwab account
and then
send it over here and you know it
creates this friction and i i don't
think that's
what's best for bitcoin uh and i don't
think that that's what's best for users
and you know i view this option and
choice that we've provided where you can
go from legacy markets to digital
markets
as just like the upward momentum of
integration of these two worlds
like i don't think it's anything that
we're doing that is uh
necessarily overly innovative it's just
that
now what we're seeing is like look hey
rest of the investment world
bitcoin and the extended blockchain
industry or crypto industry is at the
table we're not going anywhere
so uh now we're here we're part of the
portfolio
whether you guys like it or not and now
investors
are able to participate in your world
and ours from the same technology rails
that they've been doing for the last 30
years and i don't think we'll be the
only ones i think it's only a matter of
time
before you see the exchanges start to
offer
legacy assets like stock trading i think
you'll see the big
you know the mothership fidelity and
schwab start to offer crypto trading
soon and bitcoin trading i think this is
an industry you know us with choice
we're kind of running through that gap
as hard as we can right now for the
people that want one account
legacy and digital and then have the
option of how they want to hold their
digital
uh in a in a forward-thinking way so
we're trying to be our generation's next
schwab
and fidelity and really understand from
the bitcoiners
view right we understand things like our
people want to own their own keys and
our people want to keep stuff with
fidelity or our
people want to you know put it in motion
it isn't just some like
siloed and we see that extending into
the world of d5 beyond just bitcoin too
i mean people
are going to want to start baking
staking or you know earning other types
of yield in the industry out of their
retirement accounts
so i think that's where we'll stay
competitive but it's only a matter of
time before you see
the coin bases and the schwabs and the
fidelities at the mother ship level
offer both access as well and i look as
a bitcoiner i'm pumped about that
you know you know i know i'm here we're
all here to make money and you know
advance
uh commercial and shareholder terms but
um as a bitcoiner i think that it's
i'm my best thing that i can do right
now is get abby johnson's attention
that we're seeing you know 20 000 plus
people on our wait list
to open a choice account and that if
they integrate bitcoin and the rest of
the thing
uh in their their fidelity accounts
that's that's that's a big win for
bitcoin i think so
that's what i'm hoping that we're that
we're going to do and i hope that the
big players
take notice and take bitcoin our
industry as serious as we do
one of the stats that you told me early
on that blew my mind was there's like
seven million people
who already own bitcoin but they have
none in their retirement account
right and this would be the equivalent
of saying there's a bunch of people who
own stocks
but none of it's in their retirement
account like that that would just be
unfathomable
but in bitcoin that's the truth right
dude i'm
i was so and i was actually i'm so
embarrassed that i was one of them like
i bought my first
bitcoin in 2012 i brought like i sit
there i stacks like i got my wife signed
up with lolly
i do all of this stuff all right like we
like i and i didn't own any bitcoin in
my retirement account
so you know and we did the math there's
there's if you take the cross there's
two ways of getting this you take the
cross there's
7.1 million americans that have already
made
the leap all right the leap to buy
bitcoin or
um or take the dive into our industry so
to speak
um and have a retirement account but
don't
have bitcoin in their retirement account
and if you also look
at people's investable discretionary
investable money they usually have three
to four times more investable
discretionary money in their retirement
accounts
than they do their non-retirement
accounts so when i say this is the
biggest opportunity for bitcoin
especially in this kind of stock to flow
model that we look at
i'm looking at 7.1 million bitcoiners
that have three times more
investable money in their retirement
accounts that that aren't
using their retirement accounts to hodl
and you know that's all we're
that's what we're focused on and you
know if we convert some more people over
to bitcoin along the way that's great
but for now i'm we're just you know if
we stay narrow focus on that it's it's
that's big enough um and i think that
that's you know it's it's massive to me
and i think that
if you look at that there's there's 28
trillion dollars
28 trillion that is in the u.s
retirement market and
you know it's just uh i think i i just
think it's
it's a really big uh opportunity for us
to all go out and
and you know evangelize about and make
sure that these bitcoiners know
that you don't have to just have your
life your your retirement savings at
some zombie bank
that's telling you that bitcoin's not
okay and the other thing by the way
just because i'm to rant about you know
we have 50
000 people in the u.s 50 000 that work
in the bitcoin
industry or extended bitcoin industry
like blockchain industry
and most of those companies have 401ks
like employer sponsored 401ks
and what you get is some like you know
for
like some time intervaled uh like
product that rebalances for you and says
you know here put 16 000 of your money a
year in this
and we'll tell you what happens with it
later and i you know i just
it's like it's amazing to me um and you
talk to some of these ceos of these
bitcoin companies
and you know you say well why you know
your employees wake up every day to
advance this industry
but they can't access that in their
retire their employer sponsor retirement
account and i think that's an equal
injustice and it's because
the same thing like these some legacy
provider and bank is saying no no no
too risky meanwhile you know they're uh
the extent
of that is in this kind of rat fed rat
cycle of printing and
you know stock and you know this whole
stock inflation bubble there and i think
that
our you know our community has an
opportunity to opt out of that as
at the employer level too so i think
you'll see a lot of emerge there in the
next year or two as well
yeah it's absolutely fascinating what's
kind of the goal with kingdom trust like
where do you guys sit 10 20 years from
now and kind of how do you
get there right kind of just paint the
picture for us as to what you're trying
to build and what the vision is
i think the first thing i'm thinking
about right now is
just the 7.1 every day i wake up and i'm
trying to reduce
the the that number of 7.1 million
bitcoiners that own bitcoin and don't
have a retirement account
the next thing i'm looking at after that
as a business is that we actually
remember that fire truck thing i told
you about
we have we custody over 20 000 assets
um and we have about 14 billion uh in
assets under custody today
so we custody things like reits private
equity
physical golds you know it's across 20
000 of these things and what i'm
really interested here over the next 20
years is where this intersection
of our tokenized uh extension of the
bitcoin economy
grows to and how that converges with the
role of alternative asset
investing so where we're looking to be
is at that forefront of where they're
colliding and
if i in 20 years if if i ever stop
advancing bitcoin
what i hope that we built is like our as
a bitcoiner
our our community and generations
fidelity and charles schwab where you
know you know that you if
if you want to put your uh you want to
have optionality of holding your keys in
your retirement account or putting it in
motion with
with some of the most interesting baking
or staking mechanisms
and where that blend is between
tokenization and alts we're going to
live in that we're going to nail that
and we're going to do it in a timely
fashion
not too early not too late um and stay
grounded in in the bitcoin community so
that's that's i think where the
mission is i wouldn't say that we're
purely a bitcoin native financial
company because i that's not what gets
me excited
i'm excited about the integration of our
industry and the legacy industry
and how that's going to look and i think
we have the opportunity as
as believers as early adopters we have a
responsibility actually
um to advance that so that
in the next financial crisis like how we
started that
you've got individuals that aren't
completely tied in
to what nine regional central banks are
doing
and all of your assets basically have
this incredibly high correlation
to what they decide is best for your
savings and future or not
it's rather to integrate these two
worlds and make sure that uh
people are getting the choice of both of
them that's best for them so i think
that's
that's kind of our goal um we'll see i
think right now i think there's a big
enough challenge
with just the 7.1 million uh and just
knit you know just
making sure that they know that we're
here for them
they can hold their keys they can put it
in motion they can keep it with fidelity
and that if we do that well i'll
consider it access no matter a success
no matter what
yeah i always tell people that uh
there's the legacy system
the base unit of account is the dollar
it's fiat it's inflationary it's yada
or whatever there's an alternative
system that alternative system space
unit of account is bitcoin
and if you believe that there's two
systems and
the second system the one that you
weren't born into
if you think that has any chance of
being successful
one percent three percent five percent
whatever chance uh or probability of
being successful
your portfolio should match that
percentage right
and so it's kind of this thing like i
never understand why people say to me oh
i know there's two systems like yeah
that other system has a shot at it
i don't know it's two percent but like i
don't own any right it's kind of just
like all right and that's where we kind
of started which is like hey get off
zero
just get off zero percent and then once
you do that then you can work your way
into okay what is a healthy
kind of exposure to a second system that
actually
is a competitor in the arena as you
described right
yeah and i i love when did you do that
you started that like three years
was that two or three years ago i think
when you started that and and
we tried to meme that too through coin
shares and tried to extend that and
you know it's not everyone's going to be
a little different but the num you're
right i mean the number
we don't provide advice as a directed
custodian
but you know you're totally right i mean
most of our clients are now saying the
same thing like okay well it's not
zero it's not the right number uh but it
isn't 100 either and i think that's the
point
of having that choice and that
optionality of
and also there's a decision to make once
you decide by the way
that zero is not the right number then
okay i think there's a second
degree of decisions uh once you kind of
start the rabbit hole
you have a you have a next set of
choices okay it
do i want to hold this myself uh do i
want to hold
this with someone like kingdom fidelity
or do i want to put it in motion and
leverage
now for a lot of newcomers you're not
going to do the the the motion leverage
you probably start with fidelity it was
probably the easiest
but you know eventually i think that
that you know the more that we can get
people
past the initial rabbit hole and more
thinking in those terms the better
um and it's gonna it's the same we just
take the same recipe the gold guys
have done for 30 50 60 years
around that you know it's not your goal
not your it's not yours same thing with
us
uh so i think that we have as ceos
and people that are advancing bitcoin
for people that are coming in
right we're getting off zero as you say
there's also an equal responsibility
i think as a service provider
to make sure that we are also educating
them on the importance of owning your
own keys
in the same way that uh that
we've seen other bearer assets do uh
before us like gold
and but but also give optionality and
choice uh from a financial uh provider
standpoint
so that will be we still have a lot of
work though to get uh
to get people off fully off zero and i
think that
you know but but i think our mission and
the announcement in the retirement
market with fidelity
digital assets today um is is
a good step to that this is where i
should tell everyone
if you want to go sign up go to retire
with choice.com pomp
obviously uh so they think that i'm a
genius
no but uh before i wrap up i asked
everyone the same two questions then
you're gonna ask me one to finish it
uh first question is what is the most
important book you've ever read
um the most important book i've ever
read
i mean honestly it's a series of books
it's harry potter
uh i am uh you know it i love harry
potter
i think that it's a uh it has a lot of
it's taught me a lot of
life lessons what's the number one life
lesson you've learned from harry potter
expect the unexpected and be ready and
stay humble
it's three things that's pretty good uh
the second question is a little bit more
fun
aliens believer or non-believer
definitely believer
did not see the videos earlier this year
yeah those are ufos
that doesn't mean that there's aliens i
think it's i think
i think math i think you know
mathematically and probably
uh it's probably that there are uh other
organisms
that are outside of earth absolutely yes
i'm a believer
uh i'm with you on that i think the big
question is
do we want to find them or do they want
to find us right
right i think we want to find them and
that's why that's that i don't i'm i'm a
big elon fan
but for that reason yeah i i don't think
we want aliens coming here and frankly i
don't know if they want to be here in
2020 so
we're going to go what uh what one
question do you have for me to uh to
finish up
well i mean where in terms of and what
do you think
is the most important things uh that we
can do as a bitcoin community in the
next
you know through the end of 2020 in the
next two to three years i mean we've got
election cycle coming up we've got you
know all sorts of
that you're seeing bro you know we have
this interesting thing about brock
running
you know what a what do you see the most
important thing for the bitcoin
community be doing in the next year a
few years
uh and you know what how should we be
thinking about the intersection of like
money and politics too you know so kind
of a two-part
a two-part question i know it's a bit uh
that second one's kind of loaded but be
curious to your thoughts on on both of
them
yeah so for the first part i actually
think uh we should just let time
expire what i mean by that is like we're
pretty much doing everything that we
should be doing
uh i don't think that very many people
in 2008
9 10 11 thought we would get to this
point this quickly
and so when you look at it that way it's
like all right we've kind of been doing
the right things
if you talk to most big corners we
pretty much know what we need to do
right we need to get more people exposed
to the idea of bitcoin we need to get
more people
to understand why we need to get more
infrastructure in place like
all of these things are not hard to uh
kind of conceive uh
mentally it's the execution and that
just takes time right and so it's
the work you're doing it's the work that
other companies are doing to just again
build the products that are necessary to
make this stuff
much more user friendly much more easy
uh use tax advantage dollars i kind of
all the things that we've learned from
the legacy finance system we incorporate
those all the things we learned from the
tech industry incorporate those
and like just go build it so i think
that just like that stuff takes time
and i almost never talked to somebody
who i'm like wow
no one's ever thought of that idea as to
how to like push bitcoin's adoption
forward
uh it's more of just like who are the
teams they're actually building and
executing
are you doing it yeah like exactly are
you waking up every day to do it
yeah i think that's a key piece of it
and in terms of like the
kind of politics and money side like
i i've got a very i think weird nuanced
view the first being like
all politicians are the same right and
if you kind of just accept like okay if
all politicians are the same
who's in office who's not in office like
all that kind of stuff
yes there is some variation of impact
that they can have
it's just not nearly as great as we all
uh kind of fear
when it's somebody from you know an
opposing political party gets in office
so when barack obama is elected right
all of the conservatives are freaking
hell out like oh my god you know the
president's going to ruin the country
then donald trump gets elected and all
of the democrats are you know freaking
out like donald trump's gonna ruin the
country
the good thing about the united states
is that like we do live in a democratic
country that's got tons of checks and
balances and like sure can they make a
executive order and kind of overstep
balance yes but as we've seen with both
presidents
they get rained back in by the court
systems and kind of all that kind of
stuff so like
if you come at it from one the job's
really hard
right two is they're gonna make a lot of
promises they're not gonna be able to
fulfill
and then three is like as a citizen if
you rely on the government to
save you or like create this environment
where you're gonna thrive like you're
already screwed
yeah so if you kind of accept those
three things then it comes down to like
okay i'm in charge of my own life no
one's coming to save me like what do i
do
and actually think like that's the area
where uh the intersection with politics
becomes really interesting because now
what happens is
you really look at government officials
and say hey your job's not to
run my life your job is not to provide
all of these things for me
actually your job is just to give me the
tools and the access and
and kind of empower me to go do the
things i need to do for my life
and things that make me happy that allow
me to be prosperous all that kind of
stuff
and you know look everyone will argue
over what are those things and like
that's kind of the controversy of
politics
but i think that the more we can get
kind of facilitators into these
government roles where they understand
like hey as a government official
whether it's at the local state or
federal level like if i can just put the
hands in
or if i can put the tools in the hands
of problem solvers and like get the hell
out of the way
that tends to be like a pretty good
strategy um and
it actually tends to be one where like
you can get reelected a lot of times
and so i kind of think that like money
is a great example of that where
we're seeing the government step in and
be like very heavy-handed very kind of
centrally planned
and like we know best for you and then
if you look at the results already now
we're only
you know really weeks into this thing um
and i'm with you in that like there's a
lot of kind of economic carnage to come
but already the rich have gotten way
richer and therefore have gotten
absolutely demolished
and like you can say all you want that
you're saving jobs you're doing all of
this stuff but like
are you actually saving jobs right and i
wrote this whole thing today about
um if you look at the the federal
spending right so
a lot of people don't know for the last
six consecutive fiscal years
the u.s government has collected more
federal tax income
each year so last year was the most
federal revenue
tax revenue that they've ever collected
the year before that was the record
before it got broken 2019
and all the way back for six years but
every single one of those years
the federal deficit has increased as
well absolutely and so it's like wait a
second and i'm not talking about just oh
there was a deficit so the national debt
got larger
i'm talking about the actual annual
deficit that was ranked in that year
was bigger than the year before and so
you an ever expanding kind of deficit
and you start looking like well why the
hell is that happening
right and so i started doing all this
research and basically it comes down to
it's really simple it's demographics
40 of the expenses of the us government
are for people over the age of 65.
now people can argue whether that's good
bad and different you know what i
frankly don't care
but it's just now you're getting into a
world where like the only way
to continue running a country where you
have an ever expanding
annual deficit that's contributing to 26
plus trillion dollars in national debt
is you have to either one say hey this
is going to collapse at some point
or two if you were a business you'd go
to the equity and debt markets well you
don't have to go the equity in debt
markets because you got the money
printer and so what do you do you just
print money and keep going and go you
know
it's better it's better than the equity
in debt markets right and so then like
basically what i said is like okay so if
you keep going to the money printer then
you're basically arguing one of two
things either one we know what history
shows us happens when you de-value a
currency and
we're going to solve the short-term
problems and ignore the long-term impact
or two we actually think we can defy
history and we can devalue the currency
and it'll never happen to us
i wish that people would just admit like
we're in bucket one
but i actually think a lot of people are
in bucket too and there's like this
american exceptionalism or elitism that
just says like it can't happen here
right and again i don't know is that
happening one year five years 10 years
100 years i don't know but i do think
that
that is the most interesting like
vantage point or perspective
on the intersection of money and
politics and all this kind of stuff is
like
the politicians know what they're doing
yeah and they're choosing to do the
short-term things in order to get
re-elected and mitigate economic damage
in the short term all that kind of stuff
i think bitcoiners again going back to
kind of low time preference and this
like very long
systematic view or just saying this is
not sustainable i don't know when
it collapses but i'm not going to wait
for it to collapse to then like have a
safety net
i'm actually going to go and protect
myself by in uh getting exposure to
the other gladiator in the arena and
therefore i
actually am going to bet on this
competitor because i know the other
competitor
is weak unsustainable and can't go the
distance that's right
and i think it's fascinating perspective
yeah i i agree with you and i think
those two points i mean we do we can't
sit around and wait for that
for that either and but you're right i
think we're all
share your your your view is that we're
just kind of looking at this like well
this this isn't
this is not sustainable this isn't going
to work um so i think
but at the same time we we have to also
look back at our industry and say well
this isn't ready yet this is
this is this isn't as big as it needs to
be to be able to inherit that so we've
got to keep
you know you got to keep progressing
both um i couldn't agree more
where um where can we send people to
find you on the internet uh or
find out more about kingdom trust and
choice yeah i mean
uh so if you go to uh uh my twitter
handle is at ryan radloff
with two fs and then if you want to find
out about choice go to
retirewithchoice.com
and you can see all the stuff with the
optionality fidelity with casa with
digital assets with casa and the others
so um
and we're announcing a uh a big uh
partnership our big um uh uh partnership
next week with who's helping us
power the uh re the rehypothecation and
the lending and money in motion
part of your bitcoin next week so we're
pretty excited about that so retire with
choice.com
and at ryan rabbit thanks awesome right
thanks so much for doing this vlog do it
again in the future
yeah likewise palm talk soon thanks